alec castonguay michel sauget madeleine
de morais bonsoir bonsoir vaccination
rebondissons tout de suite parce qu'on
vient de parler que docteur de serre de
vaccination je vous remontent les tweets
qui ont lancé le bal monsieur rodriguez
qui disais plus tôt cette semaine près
de 50 m dos des vaccins dorment dans des
congélateurs au québec c'est plus de la
moitié des doses livrées ce qui est
exact les livraisons s'accélèrent on
doit accélérer la cadence et réponse de
monsieur dubé à mme nezha il vit l'un
d'eux ne dorment pas et sur déployés ils
seront toutes utilisées vous pouvez nous
en envoyer le triple on va tout les
utiliser très rapidement ce qui a changé
depuis longue c'est que c'est clair
maintenant michel 6 j'ai commencé avec
vous qu'on va vacciner avec toutes les
doses qu'on a reçues pour gardons au
congélateur pour la deuxième dose d'une
part et d'autre part quand on lance la
vaccination comme on l'a fait il est à
peu près évident que allait très
rapidement d'abord il fait l'épaule le
premier vaccin celui de files il fait
l'école est où ça mène place d'avc chez
7 des citations que c'était plus long
avec civile doit dernière ça va être
facile mais c'est une bonne des chiens
intégral provincial il y en a un qui a
des seringues puis l'autre des dodoz a
pas de règle pas les envoyer
il peut pas les injecté lui même alors
quand le gouvernement fédéral à se dire
aux mauvaises comme à gérer la santé
d'habitude les provinces disent et
monsieur x douce y en ait envoyez-nous
est âgé vous pour avoir plus de
fraîcheur et de modern ap on va essayer
des données ensuite mon blues reggae et
du ministre diby qui ont parti le bal
mais plus tôt cette semaine justin
trudeau a quand même dit qu'il
partageait l'impatience des canadiens
soit c'est venu je dirais gratter un
bobo lâché là les provinces vraiment pas
vibrer une corde sensible qui a agacé
les provinces en disant peut-être que
vous êtes trop lente
les provinces c'est vrai que des
provinces quand même pendant la période
des fêtes qui ont ralenti la l'opération
vaccination sauf peut-être qu'on peut le
critiquer ou le questionner mais
effectif
vivement quand tu as pas beaucoup de
doses on peut pas penser qu'il va y
avoir une opération de vaccination en
masse
il faut les doses pour pouvoir vacciner
par contre pour ce qui est de la petite
bataille fédérale provinciale oui le
sens on voit ça continuellement quand il
ya des opérations partager comme ça dans
les champs de compétence partagée mais
là je pense que les conséquences peuvent
être peut-être plus du peut-être pas
grave mais différente cette fois-ci
parce que les canadiens veulent que ça
fonctionne cette opération de
vaccination
justement parce que peut-être que
l'adhésion aux mesures de santé publique
vont dépendre en partie de la confiance
qu'on a qu'on est au bout du tunnel qui
est un dernier petit coup à donner et
qu'on va s'en sortir
si on voit des politiciens qui se
chicanent sudiste et roland c'est ta
faute ou non c'est de la tienne je suis
pas certaine que c'est optimale comme
stratégie public face à cette pandémie
alec ouais moi je trouvais ça autant du
côté d'ottawa kit québec assez inélégant
cette semaine pour ne pas dire même un
peu malhonnête
quand justin trudeau dit c'est la faute
aux provinces vacciner davantage alors
que les provinces suivait au départ les
recommandations des fabricants fallait
garder cette deuxième saison on n'avait
pas le choix
donc ce n'est pas de la faute des
provinces mais justin trudeau a essayé
de faire un petit peu de capital
politique avec sa fiesta 13 mai légal
françois legros de dire où siègent
justin trudeau ben faites juste nous
envoyer des doses comme si ottawa
essayez pas d'en aborder dans ossiam si
ottawa faisait de nombreux agents veut
proche mais non tout le monde veut des
doses à travers le monde et donc fader
moderna sont sollicités l'on côtoie
aussi peuvent en acheter plus ils vont
le faire dans les deux cas vraiment la
place du citoyen qui regardent ce qui se
dit sérieusement ça vous tente pas de
collaborer de travailler ensemble on le
nourrit petites chicanes will vaccin
c'est délicat
oui c'est sensible tout le monde devra
en avoir mais honnêtement je pense que
tout le monde fait de son mieux puis
j'ai trouvé qu'on est dedans on avait un
petit peu manqué de hauteur dans les
deux capitales c'est ça qui ont manqué
de temps pour juger aussi de la cadence
dans les provinces d'anvers ainsi dans
trois quatre jours il s'invente pas plus
le y aura un vrai
vraie lumière rouge à lui mais oui
madeleine oui j'ai eu l'impression moi
cette semaine qu'on a vu justin trudeau
lancer la balle ou province depuis que
françois legault a pris 1 bat de
baseball pee le il
je suivais cette balle loquet c'était
effectivement une opération de buzz
politique plutôt que de santé publique
ont de vue couvre-feu mais ça c'est
clair ça c'est clair que ces deux là
s'aiment beau c'est pas fini d'un couvre
feu disait ge
alec tu avais un texte dans l'actualité
dans ce beau site qui vous raconter
comment ça c'est fait depuis la fin de
semaine dernière
ce que vous dites hard un mot c'est que
le bureau du premier livre sur le go son
chef de cabinet ont été abasourdi
d'entendre un revirement ce point abrupt
de la santé publique qui en fin de
semaine vous êtes tout va bien madame la
marquise peu le rendu lundi soit c'est
tout va mal oui disons que eu une
précipitation là du côté de la santé
publique où on a révisé les chiffres
fait les projections
rêva lui tout seul lundi d'un jour puis
de la version du samedi était plus tout
à fait la même le lundi je pense je
pense pas que le gouvernement était
surpris que ça prend quelqu'un des
mesures supplémentaires à l'être
à prévoir parce qu'on les voyait bien
les chiffes pis même si la santé
publique était pas encore tout à fait
l'on se doutait au gouvernement qu'il
faudrait prolonger le confinement peut
ajouter des mesures ce qui était
vraiment surprenant c'est le couvre feu
c'est cette idée là qu'on ne peut
utiliser au québec dans notre histoire
qui davantage utilisé en france depuis
le début de la pandémie que ça ça arrive
sur le tapis qu'on en ai jamais entendu
parler dans les semaines précédant sa
sas a surpris un peu le gouvernement
parce que et je vous avoue que moi
j'étais très surpris aussi en
l'entendant parce que ça fait quand même
depuis le mois d'octobre que les cas
augmentent tranquillement de manière
plus prononcée depuis décembre qu'on
n'ait pas évoqué deux scénarios aller
par exemple comme un couvre feu
par exemple si tout va mal c'est les
hôpitaux débordent me semble-t-il qu'on
aurait dû avoir dans la filière rouge du
dernier tiroir le scénario catastrophe
on fait quoi
puis là on ne connaît jamais discuté de
cette possibilité là et que ça arrive
comme ça
lundi en fin de journée moi j'ai trouvé
le concept littéralement lundi vous
dites donc ce lundi il ya trois jours et
la confiance de presse étaient remises
ou mercredi c'est trop rapide
d'organiser ça pour le mardi
oui exactement puis c'est quand même une
mesure importante à mettre en place un
couvre-feu le sait que des corps
policiers des exceptions des amendes ça
prend un peu de logistique
alors il a fallu qu'on repose la
conférence de presse mais qu'on n'ait
pas été davantage peut-être en train
d'étudier dernier divers scénarios à la
santé publique ou au gouvernement dans
le courant du mois de décembre je vous
avoue avoir été un petit peu surpris
mais celle ci est ce que vous avez
entendu la somme des experts depuis hier
mon docteur 20 fr à l'émission ne disait
pas convaincu du tout d'autres sont
sceptiques d'eau disent mais il fallait
donner un grand coup symbolique pour
dire les rassemblements privé là c'est
terminé que vous en êtes sûr d'avoir la
même chose que vous les experts c'est à
dire oui le grand coup symbolique à
donner mais ça suffira pas si il ya
toutes sortes de gestes qui ne suivent
pas vous saviez le dr weiss ou jamais de
contrats des bons d'émission qui dit
exactement la même chose si les demi
mesures et on voit aussi qui parle à ce
gouvernement là les l'e-commerce est
donnée essentielle vont être fermées
mais on a déjà ouvert de pouvoir faire
de dieu un massage à l'auto par exemple
les chantiers de construction parfois
pas mal
vert sauf exception les gens les
entreprises manufacturières décideront
si elles sont de quelle façon elles sont
essentielles ou pas c'est qui ce que ces
gouvernements qui décide c'est chose de
si on laisse à l'entreprise
ici on est seule entreprise parce que
ces gens là au début on est bonne
oreille quand on regarde qui
qui sont les ministres un senior de ce
gouvernement là cela ne leur est tous
des comptables agréés qui viennent du
monde des affaires mais ça paraît et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens des
milieux scientifiques qui disent que
donc non ça va pas de couvre-feu savoir
pour l'aspect psychologique que ça veut
dire mais il ya trop de monde encore qui
vont qui va aller travailler qui vont
aller sur les chantiers de construction
ou ailleurs où il ya des grands risques
et puis finalement les écoles de tous
bords vont être ouvertes
on apprend aujourd'hui que l'ontario
ferme ses écoles ça rassure personne
cela je ne sais pas qui a raison
c'est clair que c'est pas évident mais
sa frappe l'imaginaire folie des
couvreurs d'ailleurs madeleine il y en a
nulle part ailleurs au canada
oui on a l'exemple de la france puis
avec l'exemple la france s'il semble
quand même que ça donnait deux des
résultats quand même là-bas peut-être
parce que ça renforçait d'autres mesures
aussi parce qu'évidemment quand tu es un
couvre-feu à 20h par exemple c'est sûr
que les bars sont pas ouverts après 20
heures
donc finalement ça vient renforcer des
mesures qui existaient peut-être pas
déjà c'est la même chose au québec par
exemple on pourra plus faire deux
parties de rock et sur une patinoire
donc peut-être que ce couvre-feu là est
accompagné de certains autres mesures et
c'est le signal que ça envoie aussi de
dire la situation et les graves
ce qu'on croit aussi à la santé publique
c'est que quand on agit comme ça par la
contrainte
c'est mieux quand une bonne partie de la
population se conforment déjà aux
mesures on veut pas avoir des
arrestations de masse parce que déjà une
population qui respectent les consignes
qu'ils restent chez eux qui ont compris
que finalement la pandémie il fallait
s'en occuper donc on veut essayer
d'atteindre ceux qui n'y croient pas
trop et qui traînent encore et qui
pensent encore que des rassemblements
sont acceptables parce qu'il change pas
grand chose à la situation rapidement
pour conclure sur le couvre-feu avec
michel sait comment vous avez trouvé le
l'élaboration de la stratégie policière
parce qu'il ya quand même la souplesse
faut le dire si j'ai besoin d'avoir
votre mère malade si vous avez votre
soeur qui a coché ici ici ici
si vous avez un chien beaucoup de gens
m'ont vu l'as acheté en gironde la
location au couchant et la location je
suis luigi plusieurs semaines sous alec
comment vous trouvez l'aménagement de
sol a commencé a été présentée
aujourd'hui écouter et essayer vidant
que des jugements qui devrait être
exercée par les policiers c'est évident
que si les gens cherchent des
incohérences ils vont trouver des plus
début de la pandémie en auto jo des
petites incohérences est impossible avec
une société aussi diverses avec toutes
sortes de situations même anecdotique
qui peuvent se produit que la cohérence
soit parfaite
est-ce qu'on peut aller promener son
chien oui est-ce qu'on peut aller joggi
non parce que c'est beaucoup plus
dangereux d'aller joggi après 20 heures
que d'aller promener son chien
probablement pas vous êtes tout seul
mais un moment donné il faut aussi
tracer la ligne puisqu'elle moins de
permissions possible le bus pensée de
garder une certaine humanité dans la
façon de le mettre en place vous allez
chercher un médicament vous allez voir
quelqu'un de malade
le policier va comprendre mais vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'aller joggé avatar
vous pouvez aussi le faire à 19h puis
vous pouvez le faire la fin de semaine
mais ça dépend pour qui
ça dépend pour qui mais samedi ça faut
pas plaisir à tout le monde c'est
évident à l'objectif n'est pas de faire
plaisir aux gens mais en même temps
c'est normal qu'ils éditent des petites
incohérences
ok très bien une chaîne amont là dessus
ou non parce que je veux vous entendre
juste un mot là-dessus il ya des
incohérences mais aussi des gens qui
vont être pénalisés déjà par exemple qui
termine le travail est quand même
beaucoup
juste je suis de rémy palet d'épicerie
il va falloir faire d'autres acrobates
pas comme ça parce qu'à un moment donné
le pour certaines personnes et on n'a
pas une société où tout le monde
travaille dans le camp 5
ça va être compliqué moi je m'attends à
ce que l'inde ou bardinon on voit des
accommodements hockey aux états généraux
revient rapidement reste deux minutes et
demie
lindy g qui aurait agi qu'un allié des
alliés des alliés de trump la fille
affirmant qu'il l'avait appuyé les douze
saynètes je pense ça symbolise bien le
largage cet homme est devenu tellement
radioactifs ils se suicident politique
si on peut parler de ça on va écouter
l'intégration vient pour conclure
ce hadith ou michel catég largué par
ceux qui étaient les plus près oui en
même temps de grâce à un show bref du
bon ben faut pas oublier ça la politique
américaine c'est le gratin me john
mccain l'ennemi juré de me jury mais
effectivement les gens sont en tête de
la ride en fait on est en train de
revenir dans le parti libéral dans le
parti républicain à une panne aussi qui
dit qu il dit ecoutez-la la réalité ça
existe et le discours de degrés au
soleil hier soir est encore bien plus le
cas du côté là on dit merci bien que si
une prise a dit qu'ils ont voté dans
quel état je donnais moindre 10-10 je
n'ai jamais reçu aucun et dentelles et à
fès ville gens qui n'avaient pas 18 ans
qu'on va t il donner moi dit non jeanne
eu aucun n'y a pas eu de fraudes
électorales point à la ligne
alors ça c'est c'est ça qui est en train
de se passer
le parti républicain les poches de mitch
mcconnell qui avaient misé des
transports qui démissionnent soul sister
grossir
est ce à dire monsieur sadi à monsieur
tron député faisait on a ressorti de
wayne madeleine
ottawa n'a que ce soit fini en tout cas
on est inquiets hier va par toutes ces
cinq là bien sûr oui mais je voudrais
que aussi ici aussi au canada il ya
personne qui a voulu défendre dans notre
championnat qui l'ont nommé pardon la
poche justin trudeau
mais tous les partis y compris le parti
conservateur qui a parmi ses partisans
des gens qui sont pros trop haut et un
autre le chef aussi voulu se dissocier
carrément de ce qui se passait aux états
unis et ne les condamnez aussi ce qui
s'est passé là bon est-ce qu'il va
partir à un mobile shell avant le 20h
étonnant quand même là il va partir la
veille au soir pour être sûr bête d'air
force one tout semble en place sinon ce
sera pour être au choix salut merci à
bientôt on va revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit